1895년 벨기에의 한 시골 마을에서 이상한 일이 벌어집니다.
장례식에 참석한 사람들이 식사를 한 뒤
하나 둘씩 몸에 이상을 느끼기 시작했습니다.
처음에는 단순한 식중독처럼 보였습니다.
그런데 증상이 조금 달랐습니다.
배가 아프고 설사를 하는 정도가 아니었습니다.
사람들의 근육이 말을 듣지 않기 시작했습니다.
눈꺼풀이 처지고 말을 하기 어려워지고
음식을 삼키기 힘들어졌습니다.
심한 경우에는 숨을 쉬는 근육까지 마비되면서
사망하는 사람들도 나왔습니다.
원인은 장례식에서 먹은 상한 소세지였습니다.
이 사건을 조사하던 벨기에의 미생물학자는
문제의 원인으로 보이는 세균을 발견하게 됩니다.
이 병은 라틴어로 소세지를 뜻하는
보툴루스에서 이름을 따와 보툴리즘
그러니까 소세지 중독증이라고 불리게 됩니다.
우리가 흔히 보툴리눔이라고 부르기도 하지만
정확하게는 보툴리눔군
그리고 이 균이 만들어내는 보툴리눔 독소라고 하는 게 맞습니다.
그런데 이 보툴리눔 독소가 연구되면 연구될수록
단순한 식중독균 수준이 아니라는 사실이 드러납니다.
이 물질은 인류가 발견한 독성물질 중에서도
가장 강력한 축에 속합니다.
흔히 아주 적은 양으로도 엄청난 피해를 낼 수 있다.
4kg면 인류를 멸망시킬 수 있다는 식의 표현까지 나올 정도였죠.
물론 이런 숫자는 조건에 따라 달라질 수 있는 자극적인 표현입니다.
하지만 중요한 것은 하나입니다.
보툴리눔 독소는 극소량으로도
극소량으로도 신경과 근육을
마비시킬 수 있는 매우 강한 독이라는 점입니다.
그렇다면 이 독은 어떻게 사람을 죽일까요?
우리 몸의 근육은 그냥 움직이는 게 아닙니다.
뇌와 신경이 근육에 신호를 보내고
근육은 그 신호를 받아서 움직입니다.
이때 중요한 역할을 하는 물질이 아세틸콜린입니다.
쉽게 말하면 신경이 근육에게 움직여라고 전달하는 과정에
필요한 물질이라고 보시면 됩니다.
그런데 보툴리눔 독소는 이 신호 전달을 막습니다.
신경이 명령을 내려도 근육이 그 명령을
받지 못합니다.
그래서 근육이 움직이지 않습니다.
손이나 다리 근육만 문제가 되는 게 아닙니다.
호흡에 필요한 근육까지 마비되면
숨을 쉬지 못하게 됩니다.
그래서 보툴리눔 독소는 오랫동안 매우 위험한 물질로 취급됐습니다.
실제로 이 독성 때문에 군사적 연구 대상이 되기도 했습니다.
독성만 놓고 보면 적은 양으로도 큰 피해를 낼 수 있으니
생화학 무기로 관심을 받을 수밖에 없었습니다.
하지만 현실적으로는 한계도 컸습니다.
보툴리눔 독소는 살아있는 생명체라고
생각하기보다는 단백질성 독소에 가깝습니다.
그래서 환경 변화에 예민합니다.
햇빛, 산소, 온도 같은 조건에 영향을 받는다는 소리입니다.
또 공기 중에 퍼트린다고 해서 원하는 대상에게만
정확히 적용되는 것도 아닙니다.
그러니까 독성만 보면 매우 강하지만
실제 무기로 다루기에는 까다로운 부분이 많았던 겁니다.
그런데 여기서 완전히 다른 생각을 한 사람들이 있었습니다.
근육을 마비시키는 성질이 이렇게 강하다면
이걸 아주 약하게 조절해서
치료했을 수 있지 않을까?
처음부터 미용 목적이 아니었습니다.
처음에는 사시치료 같은 분야에서 가능성을 보였습니다.
눈 주변 근육이 비정상적으로 움직일 때
보툴리눔 독소를 아주 적은 양으로 사용해서
근육의 힘을 조절하는 방식이었습니다.
여기서 중요한 점은 이겁니다.
독과 약은 완전히 다른 물질이라서 갈라지는 게 아닙니다.
어떤 물질은 용량과 사용 방식에 따라
독이 될 수도 있고 약이 될 수도 있습니다.
보툴리눔 독소가 바로 그런 사례입니다.
사람을 죽일 수도 있는 독이지만
아주 정밀하게 희석하고 정확한 부위에 사용하자
치료제가 됐습니다.
그리고 이후에 또 하나의 중요한 발견이 나옵니다.
보툴리눔 독소를 맞은 사람들에게서
얼굴 주름이 줄어드는 현상이 보이기 시작한 겁니다.
원리는 단순합니다.
얼굴 주름 중에는 표정 근육과 관련된 주름이 있습니다.
우리가 웃거나 찡그리거나 눈을 크게 뜰 때
얼굴 근육이 반복해서 움직입니다.
이 움직임이 반복되면 피부에 주름이 자리 잡습니다.
그런데 보툴리눔 독소를 아주 적게 사용하는 방식은
아주 적은 양으로 주사하면 해당 근육의 움직임이 일시적으로 줄어듭니다.
근육이 덜 움직이니 주름도 덜 도드라져 보입니다.
이렇게 해서 우리가 아는 보톡스 시장이 열리게 된 겁니다.
보톡스는 사실 상품명입니다.
특정 회사의 제품명으로 시작했지만
지금은 많은 사람들이 보툴리눔 톡신 시술 전체를 보톡스라고 부릅니다.
여기서 오해하면 안 되는 부분이 있습니다.
보톡스는 피부 자체를 새로 태어나게 만드는 약이 아닙니다.
피부를 직접 젊게 만드는 약이라기보다는
근육의 움직임을 일시적으로 줄여서 주름이 덜 보이게 만드는 약에 가깝습니다.
그래서 효과가 영구적이지 않습니다.
시간이 지나면 근육의 움직임이 다시 돌아오고 효과도 서서히 줄어듭니다.
그런데 바로 이 지점이 보톡스 시장을 키운 핵심이 됩니다.
한 번 맞고 끝나는 시술이 아니라 일정 시간이 지나면 다시 맞아야 하는 구조이기 때문입니다.
환자 입장에서는 번거로울 수 있습니다.
하지만 제약회사나 병원 입장에서는 반복 수요가 생깁니다.
한 번 경험한 사람이 효과를 늘리거나
고통을 느끼면 몇 달 뒤 다시 병원을 찾게 됩니다.
이것이 보톡스가 단순한 미용 시술을 넘어 큰 산업이 된 이유 중 하나입니다.
그런데 보톡스의 진짜 가능성은 얼굴 주름에만 있지 않았습니다.
보톡스는 근육과 신경 신호를 조절하는 약입니다.
그러다 보니 몸에서 너무 과하게 움직이거나
너무 과하게 반응하는 문제에도 응용될 수 있었습니다.
대표적인 것이 만성 편두통입니다.
처음에는 주름 치료를 받은 사람들 중 일부가 두통이 줄었다고 말하면서 관심이 있었습니다.
이후 연구가 진행됐고 보톡스는 만성 편두통 치료에도 사용되기 시작했습니다.
또 다한증에도 쓰입니다.
땀이 많이 나는 사람들에게 보톡스를 사용하면
땀샘으로 가는 신경 신호가 줄어들면서 땀 분비가 줄어들 수 있습니다.
과민성 방광에도 활용됩니다.
방광 근육이 과도하게 수축하면 소변을 자주 보거나 참기 어려운 증상이 생길 수 있습니다.
이때 보톡스를 사용해 방광 근육의 과도한 움직임을 줄이는 방식입니다.
방광 근육의 과도한 움직임을 줄이는 방식입니다.
그러니까 보톡스를 단순히 주름 펴는 주사로만 보면
전체 시장을 놓치게 됩니다.
보톡스의 핵심은 신경신호를 잠시 차단하는 기술입니다.
이 기술이 미용에서는 주름 개선으로 쓰이고
치료에서는 편두통, 단증, 과민성 관광,
근육 경직 같은 영역으로 확장되는 겁니다.
자, 이제 한국 이야기를 한번 해보죠.
한국은 보톡스 시장에서 꽤 독특한 위치에 있습니다.
미용 시술 시장이 크고 가격 경쟁력도 높고
시술 접근성도 좋습니다.
그래서 외국인들이 한국에 와서 받는
대표적인 미용 시술 중 하나로 보톡스가 자리 잡았습니다.
그런데 보톡스를 만들려면 중요한 원료가 필요합니다.
바로 보툴리늄균입니다.
문제는 이 균이 아무 회사나 쉽게 구할 수 있는 물질이 아니라는 점입니다.
앞에서 말했듯이 이 균은 매우 위험한 독소를 만들어낼 수 있습니다.
그래서 국가적으로도 엄격하게 관리해야 하는 대상입니다.
그런데 한국에서는 1990년대 이후
보톡스 관련 기업들이 생기기 시작했고
여러 회사가 자체 균주를 확보했다고 주장했습니다.
여기서 업계의 긴장감이 시작됩니다.
각 회사는 이 균을 정말 어디에서 구했을까?
이 질문이 바로 한국 보톡스 전쟁의 핵심입니다.
대표적으로 메디톡스와 대웅제약 사이의 분쟁이 있었습니다.
메디톡스는 자사의 균주와 제조기술이 유출됐다고 주장했고
대웅제약은 독자적으로 균주를 발견했다고 반박했습니다.
슈젤도 균주 출출 논란에 휘말린 적이 있습니다.
하지만,
이 영상에서 소송의 세부 내용을 하나하나 따질 필요는 없습니다.
일반 시청자 입장에서 중요한 핵심은 따로 있습니다.
보톡스 전쟁은 단순히 어느 회사 제품이 더 잘 팔리냐의 문제가 아닙니다.
보출리눔 균이라는 위험한 균을 누가, 어디서, 어떤 경로로 확보했는지에 대한 문제입니다.
그리고 이 균이 제대로 관리되고 있는지에 대한 문제죠.
병원에서 볼 때 보톡스는 작은 주사 한방처럼 보입니다.
하지만 그 뒤에는 제약기술, 균주관리, 국가규제, 기업간소송,
수출산업이 모두 연결되어 있습니다.
이것이 보톡스 산업의 복잡한 면입니다.
한쪽에는 미용과 치료시장이라는 큰 기회가 있습니다.
다른 한쪽에는 위험물질을 다루는 산업이라는 책임이 있습니다.
그래서 보톡스 산업은 성장 가능성만 보고 이야기할 수 없습니다.
관리체계가 함께 따라가야 합니다.
한국 보톡스 시장의 미래를 볼 때 핵심은 두 가지입니다.
하나는 성장성입니다.
한국은 이미 미용시술 분야에서 경쟁력을 갖고 있습니다.
보톡스, 필러, 리프팅 같은 시술은
외국인 의료관광과도 연결되어 있고
가격 경쟁력과 시술 경험도 강점으로 꼽힙니다.
그리고 앞으로는 치료시장이 더 중요해질 수 있습니다.
지금 한국에서 보톡스는 미용시술 이미지가 강하지만
해외에서는 만성변두통, 다한증, 과민성방광,
근육경직 같은 치료 목적으로도 폭넓게 사용되고 있습니다.
한국에서도 치료 목적의 활용이 더 넓어진다면
보톡스 시장은 단순한 미용산업을 넘어
의료산업의 한 축으로 커질 가능성이 있습니다.
보톡스는 작은 주사처럼 보이지만
그 안에는 100년이 넘는 의학의 역사와
제약산업의 경쟁, 그리고 위험 물질을 다루는 관리 문제가 함께 들어 있습니다.
결국 보톡스의 미래는 하나의 질문으로 정리할 수 있습니다.
위험한 물질을 얼마나 정확하게 통제할 수 있는가
그 통제가 가능할 때 독은 약이 되고 약은 산업이 됩니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.